en effet on attend ce moment fort ce
moment très symbolique de
volodomirzelinski ce président chef de
guerre qui va s'adresser aux euros
députés des euros députés venus
spécialement à Bruxelles pour entendre
le président
ukrainien puisqu'il n'y avait pas cette
semaine de prévu de réunion d'importance
dans cette hémicycle du Parlement
européen à Bruxelles les euros députés
vous le savez ont déjà entendu le
président
ukrainien mais par visio-conférence donc
sa présence aujourd'hui à Bruxelles
revêt évidemment une toute autre
symbolique dans son discours il va
probablement réitérer les demandes qu'il
a déjà faites hier à Paris et à Londres
de plus d'armes notamment des armes de
longue portée et des avions et puis bien
sûr l'autre enjeu de cette visite de
volo 2000 zellinski aujourd'hui à
Bruxelles c'est de presser les Européens
de livrer le matériel sur lequel ils se
sont déjà engagés parlez-nous peut-être
à X du climat qui règne en coulisses
dans les couloirs de ce Parlement
européen à quelques minutes de cette
intervention de volody mirzuelinsky
qu'on a beaucoup vu ces derniers mois
par visioconférence c'est la première
fois qui qu'il se présente en personne
et bien en effet il y a une
effervescence aujourd'hui dans les
couloirs de ce Parlement européen à
Bruxelles dans l'attente du président
ukrainien vaut lieu de mirzelinski et
puis on se demande aussi si le président
ukrainien va pouvoir obtenir
concrètement des choses des Européens
aujourd'hui puisqu'il faut rappeler que
cette visite du président
ukrainien intervient moins d'une semaine
après la visite de Charles Michel le
président du Conseil européen à Kiev
accompagné d'Ursula funderlion la
présidente de la Commission européenne
et de plusieurs commissaires européens
voyage durant lequel et bien les
dirigeants européens ont rappelé le
soutien européen à l'Ukraine une aide
militaire et économique de 50 milliards
d'euros à laquelle il faut ajouter les
17 milliards d'euros d'aide au réfugiés
ukrainien il y a aussi bien sûr le
soutien politique de l'Union européenne
à l'Ukraine avec ce statut de candidat à
l'Union européenne qui a été obtenue
très rapidement par l'Ukraine en juin
dernier donc quelques jours après ce
voyage à Kiev on peut se demander si
voliote du moments qui va véritablement
réussir à obtenir des engagements
supplémentaires des Européens mais cette
rencontre pourrait quand même servir de
motivation alors que la Commission
européenne s'apprête à sonder les 27
États membres ce week-end sur son projet
de dixième paquet de sanctions contre la
Russie